hey it's Evan I'm doing another one of
my Fiverr gigs where I review someone's
website give them some feedback and some
tips on how to make it better so today
i'm looking at wheelchair guide com my
first sense when i look at this website
is that it's a maid for adsense or made
for an affiliate type of website and
that just basically means throw up a
bunch of spammy content and then try to
get people to click on ads or click on
some kind of affiliate product for to go
often and buy something typically these
pages are really low value not much stop
put into them the reason i'm doing this
video really is the the guys behind this
page actually are trying to make a lot
of uh have an impact really provide
value for people this website was
started by somebody whose name is alex
who had a spinal cord injury and had to
use a wheelchair and couldn't find
resources online this was given to me
through a to the five or email the goal
here really is to add a lot of value to
people's lives and make it easy for
anybody who is trying to buy a
wheelchair to to know what they should
get and what they shouldn't and the
issues that they come across so first
off i would put that story somewhere on
here you know there's a little bit here
the sea there's the about the offer but
i would put the story more on the
homepage I would definitely invest in a
better design definitely that's in a
better logo you can go to sites like
99designs where you can get a logo for
think 200 bucks site design a little bit
more but but not crazy expensive and you
get the pic between lots of different
designs people will bid on it and you
you only pay when you pick something
something that you really like so I'd
really focus my efforts on doing
something like that just to make it look
better too because my initial impression
is that I think this is one of those
spammy advertisement sites and there's
so much great stuff on here it just
doesn't come across so I definitely
invest in design a little bit more and
maybe make it a wordpress base you can
update the content a lot easier the next
thing that kind of got me thinking was
there's a lot of great resources here so
there's the there's the about the author
page here
I'm talking about Alex's who's the
author I try to share a little bit more
about the story and ideally have a
picture of alex I don't know if you're
really trying to keep it incognito if
there's a reason for that but if you
tell your story people will connect to
it better they'll relate to your website
better they'll want to spend more time
with your business and so I would really
encourage you to to share your story
show a picture maybe even make a little
video as to why you made this website
why this is so important to you because
that is really going to make a huge
impact on people who are visiting your
website and for people who are you know
they just had a spinal injury they're
looking for wheelchair to see Alex's
story and see his face and see who has
gone through this and has come out on
the other side and is sharing all his
resources really tell your story like I
made this mistake early with my business
where I hid behind the content of the
famous entrepreneur stories and I didn't
share what I was doing I thought why
would people care and people kept asking
more and more but what I was doing and
why I started my business and what I was
up to and the more I shared the more
popular became and the more people got
tied to the website and this is such an
opportunity to share your story and so
this is a great start but I definitely
try to put more if if you know alex is
willing and and maybe you know you
become the face you become you become a
spokesperson for for how to how to get
through this you know really challenging
time of you know having to go get a
wheelchair because it's I've never done
it myself when I'm sure as a highly
stressful and crazy time in somebody's
life the content is really great so
there's lots of different content lots
of different pages you know wheelchair
vans wheelchair accessories I don't
pretend to know much about wheelchairs
to make these pages rank a little better
i definitely look at adding more content
is a pretty thin page so if you want to
get more Google traffic a definite look
at adding 500 words of content per page
and again make sure its high quality I'm
struggling with the purpose of this site
so it's great to inform it's great to
show all these
different options so if somebody's
asking what is the manual wheelchair
there's all this great content so this
is a good page is more content I think
you could do a lot more I think you'd
have a lot more power with it I think
you can have a much greater impact if
you shared more resources and and maybe
focus on the emotional side of things
too so these are all the technical
things to deal with wheelchairs but how
do you wake up every day you know how do
you deal with the grief and the pain and
all that side of of having to go get a
wheelchair because that that's got to
play an important part in your decision
making beyond just I know get a
wheelchair which one's the best for me
right you have to consider the emotional
state of the buyers I think you have
such a tremendous impact here to help
people in a very meaningful way and I
think you have a great start here I
think this content is great but it could
be so much better by sharing more of
Alex a story and by adding more the
emotional compounds to it and inviting
people to share their stories too and it
could be a fantastic hub for people who
want to share their stories and help
each other out and be a community I see
a lot of great potential with this site
one way to do that is to put a
newsletter on too so when somebody comes
to your website they don't just come
once and leave if you had a newsletter
you had ongoing content you could have
people leave their their names and
emails and you have a way to reach them
on an ongoing basis so that would be a
call to action you could put at the
bottom of the pages and kind of take it
from there but I like this as a start I
think again for SEO just make sure you
have 500 words per page you really you
know thicken up some of those pages like
this one that we're on wheelchair
accessories I did definitely improve the
design you know have a real logo for
your business have a real you know
template for you and maybe put in
WordPress it's easy to update and then I
really give some good thought as to what
is your goal with this you know if it's
if it's really to impact and help people
who have gone through the you know
tragic action are now forced to be in a
wheelchair I think you could serve to be
so much more than just a website that
has you know 20 pages of content and I'd
really challenge you to think about what
you could do to really
make this website a lot better if it's
sharing videos sharing resources sharing
stories of people sharing your own story
make it as personal as possible I think
you could really help a lot of people
and I'm excited for this business and I
hope you'll you'll keep me posted what's
going on anyway that's a video for today
if you guys liked it please give it a
thumbs up below it always makes want to
do more for you and if you have a
comment about this site or question for
your own business please leave in the
comment section below I always read
those love seeing the comments come in
thank you so much and I'll see you on
the next episode